envie de manger quelque chose de bon
[Musique]
quelque chose de jute
comment ça va pour moi quelque chose de
muscler
car
bien sûr barker s'excluent quoi c'est
l'été et le sexe ça fait vendre mon
choix
si nadal était va vivre de grandes
choses tu sais tu devrait enlever ton
jean fauque a nié en aérodynamisme
retraite ferr génial de grandes choses
quand on allergie au soleil
frustrant
crainte était que moi
c'est quoi
pourrait dire
non l'exclamation ce sera très bien
merci comme ça je crois qu'on l'a bien
dit arrêté bien
après
attendais pas du tout à ça à toulouse
je suis le service marketing jefri le
déguisement de burgers de jill élargit
un peu entre jambe et voilà un burger
habillé en bitume
moi j'ai compris j'ai pas de questions